SPEAKER: Processing
data can be complicated,
especially when
the volume of data
is variable, and even more so
when the data is streaming.
There's lots of it out
there, and you usually
need to work with it before you
can start to get some value out
of it.
But how do you work
with data efficiently,
and how do you scale it?
In these videos,
we're going to talk
about Apache Beam, a
flexible and open source
tool for processing data.
Specifically, it's built to
unify batch and streaming
parallel data processing.
Let's start by talking about
why Beam exists and then
go through how it works.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You may be familiar with
the original MapReduce paper
from back in 2004.
Over the years, the
usage of MapReduce
grew exponentially in Google.
But people started
running into limitations
with complex
multi-stage pipelines.
The answer to this
was FlumeJava,
which was released as
a paper around 2011.
There was also a need
for accurate, low
latency scaled pipelines,
which the MillWheel focused on.
Shortly after, these
two technologies
came together to become the
foundations for Apache Beam.
Beam is designed to
allow folks the freedom
to compose highly expressive
batch or streaming
pipelines with the
language of their choice
and to run those pipelines on
a number of different runners.
Supported languages include
Java, Python, Go, and SQL.
And you can also
choose the runner,
which is where the pipeline
will actually be executed.
For these videos, we'll
be using Google Cloud Data
Flow as our example runner.
The flexibility of Beam goes
beyond programming languages.
It also covers
lots of use cases.
You can set up pipelines
to deal with everything
from simple transportation,
which mainly involves ingestion
and simple transformations,
all the way to creating
a continuous
intelligence solution.
As you can probably see,
portability and scale
are key parts of Apache Beam.
So let's look
deeper into how Beam
works by going over pipelines
and a few key concepts.
Pipelines are basically
the description
of how you'll be
working with data.
Pipelines are essentially made
up of one or more data sources,
a collection of transformations,
and then one or more places
for the data to end up.
This pipeline also represents
a directed, acyclic graph.
Let's talk about some
of the core primitives
that make up a pipeline.
A PCollection is an immutable,
unordered collection of values.
And it can contain a bounded or
unbounded number of elements.
Beam uses PCollection objects
as inputs and outputs,
operating on them
with transforms.
A PTransform is an
operation in a pipeline.
These transforms are
basically functions
applied to each element of one
or more input PCollections.
Depending on the
runner, multiple workers
that cause a cluster may
execute the code in parallel.
Ultimately, the transform
produces one or more output
PCollections after the
function is applied.
Since PTransforms input
and output PCollections,
you can chain them together
to make a pipeline.
And then there's
the pipeline itself.
The pipeline object
helps describe
the relationship between
PCollections and PTransforms.
Since it can support one
or more inputs and outputs,
you can even chain
together pipelines
to support whatever kind of
business logic you might need.
As I said before, data can
be tricky to deal with.
These concepts might seem
pretty straightforward
when looking at batch data,
but streaming event data
can introduce more complexity.
Thankfully, Beam is designed to
handle both batch and streaming
data processing with ease thanks
to the ability to group data
using windows.
A window subdivides
a PCollection
by using the timestamps of
each individual element.
There is multiple
types of windows
that can be used
to group elements,
such as fixed windows or
session-based windows based
on clusters of events.
It makes sense that
an event probably
has a timestamp of
when it happened,
but that doesn't necessarily
mean that's when your data
processing receives the event.
Think about a mobile device that
temporarily loses connection.
You'll know the timestamp
of when the event happens,
like the different
actions a user might take
while playing a game offline.
But when the device
gets a connection
and sends all of those
events over at once,
you may see a significant
difference in the timestamps.
That's why we separate event
time from processing time.
If you were to use the
processing time as a window,
you might end up with
events in the wrong area,
and your groups could
be mixing up events.
Grouping by event time
gives you the right groups.
But that introduces
another question.
How do when you've received
all of the data for a window?
Handling late data is done
with triggers and watermarks,
but we'll talk about how that
works in an upcoming video.
So today, we covered a brief
introduction to Apache Beam
and started to go over
some of the key concepts.
There's plenty more to cover.
And in the next video,
we'll go through an example
of putting Beam to the test.
If you'd like to learn
more, check out the links
in the description below.
And as always, thank
you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]